كان يدعى بملك كره القدم اديسون ارنتس دون
سيمينتو والمدعو بولي ادهش الجماهير
بمهاراته فوق الميادين واهدافه الغزيره
بين الخمسينات والسبعينات ويعتبره
الكثيرون كافضل لاعبي كره في التاريخ دخل
بليه وهو في 17 من العمر عندما قاد منتخب
البرازيلي للفوز بكاس العالم عام
1958 وهو انجاز كراره مرتين في عام
1962 و 92,972 ولم يترك اللاعب البرازيلي
لقبا الا وناله خلال مشواره رياضي مع
الناديين اللذين لعب في صفوفهما سانتوس
البرازيلي ونيويوركوس الامريكي وحقق ايضا
عددا من الارقام القياسيه فهو لاعب الوحيد
الذي فاز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات وسجل
210180 هدفا في
1330 مباراه انجاز لم يعادله احد وتتويجا
لمسيره المذهله انتخبته الفيفا كلاعب
القرن في واللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه
كرياضي القمه وخدم بولي بلده ورياضه خارج
الملاعب ايضا فقد شغل منصب وزير الرياضه
لمده ثلاثه اعوام كما عين سفير للامم
المتحده واليونسكو اليوم يبكي البرازيل
ومحب المستديره في كل ارجاء العالم نجما
لا مثيل له